Les nouvelles technologies !
Casse-toi pendant que j'explique !
C'est quelque chose qui vous passionne vous aussi n'est-ce-pas?!
Et bah attention parce qu'aujourd'hui on a trouvé un truc inouï, exceptionnel !
Du jamais vu !
affinelayer.com/pixsrv
C'est l'abréviation de quoi ?
....
Merci..
Regardez ça
On va faire un morceau de dessin
Et ça va donner
une vraie image
Voila en gros c'est un algorithme qui va texturiser nos dessins
J'ai envie qu'on teste ça
Le blem c'est que je sais très bien que mes dessins il va jamais les reconnaitre
Il va juste créer des monstres
J'ai donc appelé quelqu'un, qui a..
le crayon facile.
[applaudissements]
Nyooo !
Bonjour!
Nyo le capuché!
Eh oui !
Vu que Nyo est un mec extrêmement cool,
il nous a ramené une tablette
On va pouvoir vraiment euh..
(qui n'est pas la mienne)
Qui n'est pas la tienne, c'est vrai
(je l'ai volée)
On va pouvoir dessiner sur une tablette
Donc euh..
Bon pour moi ca change rien
Mais pour toi ca va t'aider je pense
Moi je dessine limite mieux à la souris..
C'est te dire mon level
Je commence
Et après.. tu complexes parce que t'arrivera pas à faire aussi bien que moi
Ca c'est fort possible
Donc y a ça avec des animaux..
Avec..
Des chaussures
Et avec..
Des sacs à main
Bon on va commencer par les animaux hein..
Oui j'avoue !
On aime les animaux!
Ok c'est parti!
euhh...
comment faire...
un chat ?
Un chat qui dort c'est plus simple
Chat qui dort..
Regarde..
waw..
Nan mais attend
Il est en boule
Bon ya un problème de proportion..
Ah oui ya un problème tout court..
[rires]
Ah merde !
Voila..
Alors qu'est ce qu'il va me faire avec-
[rires]
WOW!
C'est presque ça!
On dirait presque qu'il dort!
On dirait un chat que tu as jeté et-
Non mais c'est une écharpe !
C'est une écharpe!
Une écharpe en poil synthétique
Du coup on va faire le chat..
Le chat qui fait une photo de profil
Monsieur Le Chat
Donc finalement tu fais un visage d'humain
C'est Batman..
[rires]
C'est Batman oui..
C'est complètement Batman!!
Oui c'est vrai, c'est vrai..
euhh..
Un petit museau
Ah oui un petit museau
[rires]
Oui je sais pas ce que j'ai fais...
Mais vas-y on va dire que c'est un museau
Et on va lui faire une petite bouche
Parce qu'il a le smile le chat, il est content
Là s'il me trouve un truc on est d'accord c'est le site le plus improbable du monde hein!
Oui franchement oui!
WOW!
[rires]
What the fuck mon gars ?!!
C'est incroyable !
Bon on a fait le chat qui pose,
On a fait le chat qui fait une photo de profil,
On a fait le chat écharpe,
Il nous reste quoi?
mmmh..
Le chat qui saute!
genre euh..
Oh putain!
Il a vraiment les pattes écartées
Et tu sais il ont leurs pattes comme ça tu sais..
Putain on dirait une grenouille
Oui..
Je crois que j'ai fait une grenouille..
[rires]
Attends nan mais là je pars en couille, mais totalement quoi
C'est juste scandaleux
C'est pas grave, on va voir
Vas-y fais process
[rires]
Oh wtf
Franchement on pourrait faire un film d'horreur avec tout ça
Mais totalement!
On dirait vraiment qu'on a dépecé un truc là
Je pense qu'il est plus sage..
après cette horreur..
de te laisser le crayon.
Fais-nous le chat qui dort!
Deja il y a une texture
il y a des poils
Ce qui est finalement..
le symbole du chat
Sa queue on dirait un gourdin
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave..
Non mais c'est une très belle queue.
Je l'ai fait un peu petit
mais pour qu'il tienne dans leur
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave..
C'est pas grave
Au pire au dessus tu peux dessiner un soleil par exemple
Il est posey
Il y a les petits oiseaux
Je sais pas ce qu'il va te créer avec ce soleil
Mais je sens qu'il va nous faire un truc mon gars!
OOOOHHH!!!
Mais qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé???!!!
Eh il a détecté l'oeil !
Mais mon gars !
Parfait!
Oui il a fais l'oeil !
Il a fais un Seigneur des Anneaux finalement !
[rires]
Mais par contre le chat en lui même franchement il est..
Il a des moustaches un peu hein!
Si je le vois a la SPA je suis pas sur que c'est lui que je choisis..
Mais..
INTOLERANT!
Franchement ça a donné un chat!
Allez vas-y!
Euh.. chat qui saute
Ou sinon tu peux faire un Shakira..
OHHHH!!!
J'ai pas compris.
(Musique EPIQUE ! )
Est-ce qu'il va nous refaire Sauron ?
[rires]
C'était tellement glauque !
Ohhh mec!
En vrai ça va..
Eh mec c'est ouf!
Nan ça passe..
Franchement mec,
c'est pas dégeu
Allez vas-y suivant!
Eh tu veux pas faire un truc qui n'a rien à voir?
Fais genre un pingouin
Nan je sais pas, un animal
Qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ?
Je peux faire un...
Un aigle si tu veux
Vas-y fais un aigle!
[musique épique]
Ça va sinon ?
Ba écoute euh..
Starfoullah
Oh..
Ouais allez process
Oh là c'est..
Il ressemble presque plus à un pigeon
Oui, oui !
Un peu dégeu!
Tu sais qui sort de la flaque d'eau parisienne !
Je sais pas ce qu'on est en train de faire aux animaux mais c'est terrible
Fais un insecte !
Ah ouais un insecte !
Oh ou une araignée ?
Vas-y fais une araignée!
[musique epique]
OHHHH!!
Elle est bien dégeue !
C'est une boule de poil !
En vrai ça passe!
Mec ça passe de ouf !
Elle est trop mignonne en vrai !
Hola hola t'es chelou !
Allez ça dégage !
Oh mec !
On reviendra après sur les animaux,
Maintenant c'est le moment de faire plaisir,
aux gens qui aiment la mode
On va designer des chaussures !
Ok je commence
Allez, c'est à toi !
Est-ce que tu veux une chaussure ?
J'ai tellement d'inspi en moi
On en est là..
Vraiment la technique du CE1
Voilà, c'est ta chaussure
Et fais la semelle en dessous..
Tu me dis pas quoi faire
Oh t'as vu la semelle ça tout changé
Oh putain alors là !
Là on est passé d'une Converse à une Stan Smith c'est incroyable
Là c'est parfait
T'es prêt ?
Ohh!
GG mec!
Personne l'achète mais c'est le jeu
Allez fais-nous rêver
Parce que là à un moment je...
j'en ai marre de..
d'etre nul.
Je vais faire une botte en caoutchouc
ah ouais ok
Genre la botte quand il pleut quoi
Quand il pleut et que t'as 6 ans
Une petite ombre
Regarde
Oh oui
Alors ça...
Nan mais il va nous faire du duvet mec..
Sur la botte là..
Ok, ok vas-y
Botte en caoutchouc
Prise 1
Attention, attention, attention..
Oh !
Mon design jsuis content
Par contre la couleur..
Mais putain mais c'est quoi cette couleur ?!
Mais tu sais c'était tendance à une époque les bottes en caoutchouc de toutes les couleurs
Nan...nan..
AH SI !!
Si si si si !
Euh bon..
C'est pas mal..
Mais franchement euh..
C'était mieux les animaux..
J'avoue !
On va pas se mytho !
Allez on passe au 5e !
Ahhhh!
Je vais te faire un bag de ouf mec
Oulah..
Il nous tente euh..
En fait tu sais ce que je t'ai fait là comme sac ?
Je t'ai fait le Tea Bag !
OOOHH!!
Eh bien on est loin dans la video
les entrailles de Lucas Auchard
Qui arrête, désormais, sa chaîne Youtube
Attends nan
Je te fais un vrai bag..
C'est vraiment gentil de faire semblant d'être impressionné
C'est un très beau sac en vrai !
Oui oui oui..
OOOHHH !!
WTF ??
WHAT THE FUCK ??
Il est parfait !
Mec !
Incroyable !
Nan mais là gros !
On peut être sûr d'un truc,
c'est que ce sac n'existe pas.
C'est le made in Squeezie
Je suis choqué !
Je me suis senti dessinateur pour la premiere fois de ma vie !
Mais qu'est ce que je peux faire après ca ??!
Comme à l'oral du BAC quand tu passes après un élève trop chaud,
tu sais plus quoi faire !
Et si on faisait le sac à dos de Dora l'Exploratrice ?
Il fait tellement peur ce sac
Vas-y process
Attention !
Oh le cauchemar !
Alors on n'a pas trouvé le sac de Dora pour toi ma petite chérie
Mais on t'a trouvé ça
Le cauchemar mec t'imagines t'offres ça a ton enfant !
Ça va plaire à tes copains hein !
Oh je suis choqué !
Attends je peux tenter un truc ?
Vas-y, vas-y, vas-y !
Attention coup de poker
Ok
Parfait
Eh mais mec !
Ya un truc entre moi et ce site
Il se passe un truc
Il m'a fait des vielles textures de ouf ici tu vois
Ça c'est stylé
Par contre on dirait des peaux de baleines
J'allais le dire on dirait parfaitement des peaux de baleines c'est scandaleux !
Du coup j'aimerais re-tenter ma chance pour euh..
...les animaux
On fait un duo
Genre moi je fais la forme globale
Et toi..
Ok vas-y !
Oh putain c'est beau !
Ça c'est du travail d'équipe ça !
C'est ça la collab !
Je te laisse faire
Je fais les traits
Oh c'est beau ce que tu fais !
Putain mec je ne me suis jamais autant concentré !
Essaye de faire les ronds
Tu sais que j'ai fais toute à l'heure
Ça marchait bien..
Ah oui les ronds !
Ça marche, ça marche..
On parie?
Allez !
Il est IMMONDE !
Il faut remplir ses yeux !
Remplis ses yeux !
Fais un truc..
Genre des yeux..
Oh putain !
Nan mais là il..
Franchement ça va..
Ah mais on avait fais un truc hein!
Franchement c'est pas mal..
Ça va..
Je veux qu'on finisse sur un truc-
Je veux terminer sur un truc parfait.
Et si on fait un humain ?
Si on fait un vrai visage ?
Genre réaliste
D'humain
Tu veux que je fasse ça ?
Vas-y, vas-y tente
On termine sur ça
On termine sur une chimère
Entre un chat
et un humain
Attention messieurs dames
Ça va être incroyable
C'est parti !
[musique épique]
Oh mec !
L'homme-chat !
Gros!
On a crée-
On a crée un X-MEN
Bravo! Felicitations !
Felicitations je vous donnerai 2M d'euros pour ce design, bien-joué
Je le veux livré sous 24h
Eh bien voila les amis c'est la fin de cette video avec Nyo sur euh..
euh...
affinelayer.com/pixsrv
Merci donc n'hésitez pas à passer voir la chaine de Nyo
Bon normalement il ne bosse pas sur cette tablette donc il a fait de son mieux
Surtout que c'était un logiciel de merde
Enfin c'était meme pas un logiciel
C'était juste un..
un truc..
Eh bah hésitez pas à aller voir sa chaine
Et puis hésitez pas à aimer la video si ça vous à plu
On a fais des chimères, on a fais des trucs de ouf
On a un peu euh..
Un peu designer de la nouvelle mode aussi finalement
Niveau chaussures, sac euh...
Tergiverser
On a tergi-....
À bientôt.
Une très belle conclusion!
Merci beaucoup!
Merci à toi !